what a goal is to you know solve a
circuit and and hopefully what I'll show
you today is that we are going beyond
what is considered solved so neurons in
our brain are often classified as
inhibitory or excitatory depending on
how they affect the optic partners
however in a growing number of regions
including the hippocampus habenula
auditory brain stem and spinal cord you
have neurons that release both an
inhibitory and excitatory
neurotransmitter now on the surface that
doesn't make sense inhibition and
excitation are going to cancel each
other why push the brake and accelerator
at the same time problem that have
puzzled retinal scientists for more than
25 30 years when they realize is a burst
amacrine cells which lie in the heart of
the Direction selective circuit are both
gabaergic and cholinergic neurons panic
gotta try to convince you today that in
fact by finally controlling the spatial
temporal properties of gabaergic and
cholinergic transmission the system can
actually offer a way to provide neural
circuits with a finely balanced
inhibition and excitation and this is
critical for high fidelity computation
of direction but before I go to that let
me summarize 50 years of work that led
to the solution of oh the DA circuit
Direction is is coded by the retina and
outputted to higher brain brain regions
by these directional selective ganglion
cell years ago when people moved a
stimulus across his receptive field and
saw that it didn't respond and the same
stimulus caused the robust response when
the stimulus moved in the opposite
direction okay that's cool its preferred
then let's go it's now direction listen
orthogonal directions you get a media
now therefore types are the many types
of d/s ganglion cells in the retina
and what I'll focus on and the ones that
code the cardinal directions okay there
four types of these these are the on/off
kinds of diaz ganglion cells now the the
main focus of the last 50 years of
research was having these cells you know
get this require this direction
selectivity and beautiful work from
Winfred danks lab using two photon
calcium imaging showed that the
starburst amacrine cells played a key
role so when they measured calcium in
the distal dendrites and move stimulus
from the soma to the dendrite they saw
very very robust calcium signal in the
distal dendrites and this is where the
neuron is thought to release
acetylcholine and gaba from these distal
dendrites note there's no acts on to
these neurons so they it's a kind of
Dendur Dianetics and apps now if you
move the stimulus in the opposite
direction going from the distal tips to
the soma then you get very little
response so the the dsl of these
amacrine cells the dendrites of these
cells you can themselves compute
direction now it's while these can
compute direction the next challenge is
how does that direction get transferred
to the ganglion cell and output as
spiking to the rest of the brain now if
this is non-trivial because if you
connect both these sides of the dendrite
to a ganglion cell you run into the
problem in that it'll it'll be direction
on what as the stimulus moves right
across the receptive field you get
they'll cancel out from both sides so
you need a very very selective wiring
and indeed again when prince to the
channel challenge invented scanning
block electron microscopy and showed
that these cells were actually
asymmetrically connected to ganglion
cells that's what's shown over here you
see these radiating dendrites of
starbursts pointing in different
directions but they connect two very
very specific populations of ganglion
cells coding the cardinal directions
okay so that way the direction
selectivity can be transferred to the
next to the next layer
this case you have images moving across
the retina stimulating the
photoreceptors which stimulate bipolar
cells and stimulate both the on and off
layers of these ganglion cells but
importantly the starbursts only
connected on the null side so when the
stimulus moves in from the north side
they activate the dendrites in the
appropriate direction and that provides
a very powerful inhibition and shuts off
spiking in the directional selective
ganglion cell on the other hand if the
stimulus comes in from the preferred
side you don't have the starburst and
it's going in the opposite direction
that the dendrites are activated in so
you don't get that powerful inhibition
and you get beautiful spiking so again
this was years ago this was the model
put forth and the circuit was considered
solved so when we when we look major
problem we saw was and this is kind of a
general problem in the brain we know
that feed-forward inhibition is
extremely important and if you're going
to use different that you're going to
run into the basic problem off how do
you set the gains of these synapses to
be balanced under diverse conditions in
any part of the brain when you need
inhibition and excitation to be balanced
how does that up curve and when you know
you're using neurons with very distinct
biophysical properties and for this
happen you need the gains in a in a very
very asset manner and to give you a
better appreciation of this let's
consider contrast for example have the
circuit functioning on the high contrast
the fidelity of transmission is very
high as you see over here from the trial
to trial variability ok this is spiking
in a diaz ganglion cell however when you
lower the contrast what you see the the
the fidelity of transmission is greatly
decreased now what you see is the
excitation I can response bouncing a lot
in time if excitation to the ganglion
cell is going to fluctuate in time
and you need efficient to lamp that down
how do you do that because your
inhibition and excitation are not going
to be balanced anymore okay and to solve
this we hypothesized that the retina
uses two tricks sorry I mean that even
when you use a high-contrast you get a
beautiful Direction selectivity and this
is plotting the the response against
different directions and showing that it
likes this direction we lower the
contrast even though you have very few
spikes it's beautifully directionally
tuned okay again saying even though you
have these fluctuations the balance of
inhibition and excitation is maintained
you always have more inhibition than
excitation in the null direction and
more excitation than inhibition in the
preferred direction okay and the main
question is how do you balance this
inhibition excitation or diverse
conditions and and the tricks the retina
uses what we can I try and describe is a
slightly different configuration of the
circuit okay since f having feed-forward
excitation and feed forward pose is that
in fact it's a sealer choline and gaba
that's driving the system bipolar cells
activate the star bus but not the
ganglion cell directly a fundamentally
different plan of the retina so to speak
where normally you have excitation going
through bipolar cells being modulated by
inhibition here I'm saying no the
excitation is not reaching ganglion
cells directly but the bipolar cells are
stimulating a seal choline and gaba from
this network of starburst ganglion cells
starburst amacrine cells in the second
part so so in the first part of the talk
i'll show you a lot of biophysical
details oh you that it is a seal calling
and not luta mate that drives the d/s
ganglion cell evidence to show how these
can be differentially transmitted to the
ganglion cell and the gab and the ACH
don't simply cancel each other off okay
the balance is made
in a directional select a manner and
then finally in the second part how its
differential expression of AMPA and NMDA
receptors in result in the rerouting of
that information through the stack
network instead of directly through the
ganglion cell although NM itch
interactions operation we're using is a
whole mount retina where we have relayed
the retina of a mouse on a flat circle
is a ganglion cell oscar p you can
identify the directional selective
ganglion cells I over and record action
potentials in this case we decided to
play a movie which was taken from from a
camera mounted on a mouse's head as it
moved its cage and you see the luminance
fluctuations and this ganglion cell is
responding to very significant the
stimulus moves a stimulus mover feature
moves in the in its preferred direction
okay most striking part over here is
when we put on and hold in receptor
blocker okay bc ons disappears and this
was really surprising because again it's
saying that answers being mediated by a
seal choline basically now people had
done this pharmacology for many many
years since 30 40 years they've been
putting on acs occurs what was different
about big one possibility was in the
natural movie the the contrast is much
much lower than what the the I used in
previous experiments which are just
simple spots moving on a high contrast
background so we decided to test the
effects of contrast on the role of
acetylcholine on responses mediated by
different contrasts so here you see a
response needed by high
contrast bars and if you put on a
silikal in blocker you lose master to
the response but the remaining response
is very robust and it's still
directional selective and this is what
people had reported before however if we
lower the contrast what do you see is
something I king is that the response
again is completely flattened out okay
so again this effect that we're seeing
appears to be contrast dependent do this
in a little more quantitative we're
using voltage-clamp techniques but
essentially you see the same thing so
again we're looking at epscs now and you
see an on/off component coming as the
stimulus edge comes in and out of the
receptive field and that's driven by on
and off bipolar cells but as you
increase the contrast the response gets
bigger if you block acetylcholine
receptors you lose all the low contrast
responses over here and that's kind of
summarized over here that's the total
response if you block acetylcholine
receptors you see the curve shifts to
the right and the initial component is
if you do a subtraction you realize that
this whole initial component is needed
by acetylcholine receptors now this is a
big statement to make because it's
challenging the fundamental plan of the
retina and of course it's just using
pharmacology and and and and the
sumption here is that silkolene blockers
only working postsynaptically now of
course anyone who's done pharmacology on
the owner network realizes they're
probably many ways to explain this sort
of data again and we see the expression
of acetylcholine receptors in amacrine
cells and bipolar cells and other
circuit elements okay so how do we
realize that this is actually due to
postsynaptic acetylcholine receptors
this we kind of devised a novel method
in which we take advantage of the
biophysical properties of the different
receptor types and use a sort of
deconvolution analysis which i'll
explain in a second oh to do to
understand what the biophysical
properties of cereal choline ass line in
which our adoption was expressed
only in starburst amacrine cells okay
[ __ ] all other receptors in the
circuit and stimulated blue light and if
we held a cell at different voltages
what we see that you that the current
decreases as we depolarize the cell but
then when we further depolarize the cell
the current rectifies and that's kind of
some right but so you see that this
acetylcholine receptor has a large
inward rectification you don't get much
of an outward current until you go much
a high-end potential so it has a
distinct signature and this is kind of
consistent with the ceiling but it gives
us a handle on how to extract this
conductance from the whole network
activity on trust if you look at the
biophysical properties of gaba you see
is it's it's almost linear and reverse
around minus 60 and ampa receptors are
completely linear and reversed on zero
so now we can you know given this
information and understanding of the
biophysical properties of these
different receptor type ask what is the
natural response made up off okay and
and that's five minutes early me to rush
so in these experiments we've also
blocked nmda receptors by putting an
antagonist because these really
complicate the analysis and NMDA
receptors always secondary so we didn't
worry about that too much now what we
did is not put any blockers for serial
collina gaba and we measured the light
response at different holding potentials
again asked okay how can we what are
these responses made up off to
understand that better if you plot the
IV of the initial response you see the
response is kind of rectifying okay at
you can actually fit it some of these
basis functions and ask what is the
weight of each of one of these functions
alized that the initial response is made
up of ninety percent of a scene
rectifying this is giving us a direct a
readout of what is being released in the
circuit without the use of pharmacology
fires a little in a careful water you
can do that for different phases and you
see art of the response the response now
looks a little more linear but its
reversal of shifting towards minus 60
and we try and do that again a fit that
fit the curve with different basis
functions you see that most of it is
gaba and acetylcholine and ampa is
minimal okay now these are quite subtle
changes right i mean is this linear or
is this and how robust is this data and
i'm going to bore you with more
biophysical details because this is this
is cool and it's kind of on my mind and
i'm a bit of a geek so you can see over
here the Gabba ACH if we model it with
gaba ACH it fits beautifully if you try
and model the same curve with ampere and
gaba ok it does very poorly again even
though the data you can see where it's
going off if you go to the high contrast
conditions where you do have ampere then
the ACH and gaba you still get large
errors and the ampere and gaba you get
big errors but now you need all three
components to minimize and get a good
fit of the data you can take this a step
further when you take the same condition
and block acetylcholine receptor and
those conditions the AC agent gaba don't
fit the data very well but the amp and
gaba fit the data really well so all we
can go through i wouldn't i'm gonna skip
these details below in question is now
given that we can start to pull out all
these different receptors in an intact
circuit how does the conductance evolve
over time ok and so we did that similar
analysis for every millisecond long
the light along the response as the
light bar sweeps over the receptive
field bonds oh when we do that we come
up with this picture so first we measure
spiking and what we see is that the GABA
conductance in the preferred direction
is small and delayed compared to this
huge GABA inhibition in the null
direction look at the cereal Colleen
okay it's well in the null and preferred
direction and the ampa is is very little
so if you sum the acetylcholine gaba you
immediately Lorelei's as a window in
which you can get beautiful spiking
whereas in the null direction the null
inhibition completely cancels out it's
very powerful compared to the
acetylcholine it no spiking so now this
is not surprising in that inhibition and
excitation a change in balance what is
surprising is that this is not glutamate
and acetylcholine again that's what's
being revealed over here and I'm arises
that this also many cells so you always
see that excitation is equal to is equal
in the preferred in our direction and
falls along a straight line agenda now
direction if you look at the balance
it's always positive in the preferred
direction and negative in another
direction and you look at the timing is
always before I a direction they always
synced up okay so so again it's saying
you have a system and an endogenous
system when you go contrast stimuli
across the retina it's a sealed Colleen
and and gaba that are driving that the
computation how do you actually prove
this and for this we resorted back to
went back to optogenetics oh we took
went back to our channel rhodopsin mice
and said okay let's compare the
direction selectivity under normal
conditions to that driven by
channelrhodopsin at we measured
Direction selectivity in a ganglion cell
use
low light levels okay wait to load to
stimulate our Dobson but the
photoreceptors intact and much more
sensitive than channelrhodopsin so you
get beautiful normal responses on a
cocktail of antagonists to completely
block the photoreceptors and then and we
increase density of the light stimulus
now you see beautiful spiking again art
is if you look at the directional tuning
it's completely matched with that driven
by photoreceptors l types so you can see
the direction in in control is plotted
against the direction and
channelrhodopsin the light lines up
along the diagonal and similarly the
directional index selectivity index it's
actually stronger and channelrhodopsin
conditions because of you this suggests
this can it proves that the starburst
Network alone has the capability of
driving directional selectivity or
controls to show that okay there's no
residue for the receptor activity
college you can see that easily of GABA
receptors you see the response becomes a
symmetric and now you have a lot of
activity and if you put on a silica lean
blockers Oh residue glutamate activity
in this condition importantly if you
look at the dew voltage clamp analysis
under these conditions where photos
[ __ ] you see the same kind of
phenomenon where you have a larger
inhibition in the now direction and
excitation is equal so this is quite a
neat system right because but the same
neurons that are releasing a serial
choline and gaba but somehow the
response that the e i ratio is different
in two different directions exactly how
that happens is not one hundred percent
clear if you look at the connectivity
but we said the scanning block and you
look at the synaptic connections you see
the stab us are connected only in the
now direction
that raises the question when the
stimulus comes in the preferred
direction how do you get preferred
excitation okay there is a little bit of
things that we need to figure out and
the two possibilities one is we need to
have preferred sacks on the preferred
side because that's what happens when
the stimulus comes in you get a sealed
Colleen okay now why their synaptic
connections were not observed in the
scanning blocky m and B first you could
have different synapses for sealed
choline and gaba boolean one's a soon a
symmetric you would you would still see
the same but that would require the
synapses to be morphologically different
and that's why they were missed in the
e/m recordings the second possibility
which is also as likely is that perhaps
acetylcholine is not being transmitted
why are conventional synaptic mechanisms
look all around the brain acetylcholine
is actually transmitted through
paracrine fashion okay so this a sealed
call incensed by the ganglion cells
might come from starburst amacrine cells
but not require a defined synaptic
connection okay that's how we think
about how the same neurons releasing a
seagull calling and gaba and create very
distinct responses depending on the
direction of the stimulus this is just a
side note I mean what I've shown you is
that direction selectivity in the
ganglion cells does not require bipolar
cells and it's coming from the starburst
network in fact this was a bit of
contention because a new model that just
came out from Sebastian songs lab
predicted that you need different types
of bipolar cells to generate the
Enright's of starburst amacrine cells
yeah the data saying you don't even
without these bipolar cells you can
generate a very robust Direction
selectivity that matches the endogenous
one so auto needs to be revisited so let
me go to part two of the talk which is
to understand
you have a common set of bipolar cells
you know and you need them to be
activated you need the stab us to be
activated in order to release
acetylcholine is not the glutamate
activating the directional selective
ganglion cell itself right and if you
measure make measurements in a pairwise
fashioned from a starburst and a
direction ganglion cell you see the
following and this is again increase in
contrast timilai you see that the
starburst start to begin start to
respond before the ganglion cell and
that's kind of powdered here for a bunch
of cells and you can see there's at
least a three-fold difference in the
contrast sensitivity of the sacks and
the d/s ganglion cell dubbers responding
at a lower contrast and this allows them
to depolarize and release the
acetylcholine and therefore stimulate
the ganglion cell but why is the
ganglion cell not responding when the
starburst is so I mean we assume that
they're coming from the same bipolar
cells in the same bipolar cells are
connecting to both bezel verify that we
went back to the scanning blocky em
where we identify and this is done with
in collaboration Kevin briggeman
identifies Direction selective ganglion
cells using calcium imaging and then
goes and scan scans the whole
finger reconstruction of a bipolar cell
terminal and the starburst tends to give
you what kind of resolution we have it's
kind of beautiful lies what precise is
precisely is being connected to what at
which types that many types of bipolar
cells and are these bipolars really
shared between yang an example of a
bipolar now if you if you look at the
bipolar cell terminal over here and ask
what is its partners okay you can see le
that they connect the shared between the
starburst and the d/s ganglion cell it's
the same bipolar cell terminal can does
connect to the and the sack so now we're
again if the same bipolar cells driving
both the cells then why is the sack
responding and not the Dia's ganglion
cell and the solution to this apparent
conundrum came when we considered NMDA
receptors periment what we did was
looked at the spontaneous activity with
gaba inhibition blocked and instead of
holding the cell at minus 60 we held a
cell at last 50 millivolts and albus be
held in minus 60 millivolts to see the
ampere and under these conditions
suddenly we see why we were missing what
we were missing ever large DBoys input
to the sacks if you do a correlation
Elsa now if you block NMDA receptors and
you look at the residue ampa receptors
firstly notice it's very little this is
kind of yet because normally a glutamate
synapse is dominated by ampa receptors
absolutely dominated by nmda receptors
literature more carefully but I don't
think there's a single case maybe Angus
can tell me whether you have a synapse
not not in the immature system that's in
the mature systems as dominated by nmda
receptors and more importantly that the
residual ampa receptors are very weakly
correlated suggesting them might be
coming from a different source whether
characterized them again with bad
recordings and and shine light this time
you see now the sack epscs the inputs to
this X can a match up with the NMDA
receptor responses in DF ganglion cells
so there's the same kind of bipolar
cells but that mismatch was coming
because the NMDA the ganglion cells had
nmda receptor L importantly these NMDA
receptors alone can't drive activity ok
have a robust spiking response and block
ampa you see the responses are
completely gone if you take em cell and
voltage clamp it and hold it at
different potentials you see these huge
a shape IV which is a signature of nmda
receptors is a lot of glutamate being
released into the cell nmda receptors
are sensing the glutamate but they're
not driving spiking so they're
completely silent okay which is not ever
then that's emerging then is if you look
at the inputs to the ganglion cells you
have an nmda component and you have an
acetyl choline component and the ampere
component is is is actually coming on it
which suggests that it's not ampere
that's
recruiting the NMDA receptors but it's
all in that's recruiting the NMDA
receptors actly we just use pharmacology
where you show that if you look at the
earth max contrast you find that
acetylcholine receptors a block the
responses are shown earlier but even if
you block nmda receptors you see a large
decrease in the response acted both
transmitters are being used suggest as a
highly nonlinear interaction between
acetylcholine MDA that causes the strobe
are spiking estes out further but what
we did is the following experiment to
kind of by this model in which we add
both we imagine that the lowest contrast
that there would be only nmda receptors
and as but the sacks to threshold they
would release acetylcholine and gaba and
then that acetylcholine would interact
with the NMDA at threshold you see that
the response is beautiful because
inhibitions already kicked in over here
at sub-threshold regions there's no
response so we don't know whether
inhibition is kicked in or not but to
reveal the NMDA receptors all we needed
to do was depolarize the cell a little
bit right and then you see indeed get
inputs from bipolar cells but they are
non directional and and this is just
like so so I guess I finished early
maybe your time I really set me off
memorize what what I'm trying to say
over here so we have a system where we
need to look at the effect motion at
different contrast when Louis contrast
now we can't get balance there's no way
to do it because the cells you know
inhibition and excitation can't be tied
in together
Oh biophysical tricks that the brain can
use but what the retina does use is
enemy receptors to kind of get rid of
this and not to allow this imbalance to
cause spiking and send noisy information
to the brain no there's glutamate being
released okay there's no response only
when the starburst reaches threshold
contrast and starts to release
acetylcholine and GABA do you start to
see responses in the ganglion cell ours
now however strongly you stimulated the
ACH and GABA always tied together
because they're merging from the same
cell so the stronger you stimulated with
the higher the contrast the more the
GABA and the more the ACH so this system
always stays in balance then although
ACH and GABA being released by the same
cell did not the differentially
transmitted to the ganglion cell and
that I showed you was because the GABA
was a symmetric and the silicon the
ganglion cell was symmetric pitiful
trick to get very very balanced
inhibition bipolar cell input doesn't go
completely to waste okay you activate
NMDA receptors very strongly and this as
has the added effect of boosting this
week cholinergic input especially yet
not interact in the null direction I
can't boost those responses because
they're being shunted and nmd is very
voltage-dependent so it's a very
beautiful system of amplifying these
preferred direction and really increase
in leather allows us to have contrast
invariant duet des tuning so at every
contrast the inhibition and excitation
stays balanced and bust computation and
I just like to thank all the people to
donate them
funding agency the Canadians finally
blindness and brain Canada so thanks for
attention